noch fließt hier russisches Öl in die
Raffinerie in gut drei Monaten ist
Schluss der Bund stellte das Unternehmen
nun unter Treuhandverwaltung um
Arbeitsplätze zu sichern manche atmen
auf doch das Wort Treuhand Weg bei
vielen in Schwedt auch schlechte
Erinnerungen Trojaner
wurde DDR zusammen geballert wurde mit
BRD also Sammy soll man zusammen vereint
oder nicht die ganzen Firmen alles
kaputt gegangen sind unter Treuhand na
ich find's gut also ist ja gut für die
Region gut fürs Unternehmen auch für uns
dass wir erstmal jetzt positiv in die
Zukunft fliegen können es geht um den
Erhalt von 3000 Arbeitsplätzen in der
Region und die Energieversorgung
deswegen greift der Staat als Treuhänder
ein die PCK Raffinerie ist bis heute ein
Leuchtturm im Osten in kaum einer
anderen Branche ist es gelungen einen
Betrieb den es schon zu DDR-Zeiten gab
effektiv am Laufen zu halten
Mitte der 60er Jahre geht das PCK das
petrolchemische Kombinat an den Start
[Musik]
die Schieber an der Pumpanlage wurden
geöffnet der Weg war frei sowjetisches
Erdöl strömte in schwefels
russisches Öl macht aus einem kleinen
Ort mit knapp 4.000 Einwohnern eine
blühende Stadt und einen
Industriestandort tausende Wohnungen
entstehen für Arbeitskräfte die aus der
ganzen DDR nach Schwedt strömen bis Ende
1965 sind es 23.000 Einwohner einige
Jahre später schon
54.000 Liana Zaug ist in Schwedt
aufgewachsen erinnert sich
unsere Eltern sind aus der ganzen Region
also aus der ganzen Republik früher
hierhergekommen und wir sind davon schon
wieder Ableger und haben Ableger also
Kinder Kindeskinder die natürlich von
diesen PCK und diesen kleinen
firmenringsherum auch Leben schon damals
ist das PCK ein Jobmotor den Zugezogenen
hier soll es an nichts fehlen
im Bauplan für 1966 das neue
Gesundheitszentrum
[Musik]
Schulen entstehen am laufenden Band denn
Schwedt ist eine Stadt der jungen Leute
Schwedt wird eine kinderreiche Stadt
8000 Menschen arbeiten zur Blütezeit des
petrolchemischen Kombinats kurz PCK
genannt in der Stadt dann kommt die
Wende und die Treuhand sie hat damals
das Ziel volkseigene DDR-Betriebe für
die Marktwirtschaft fit zu machen die
wenigsten überleben
das nun wieder eine Treuhandverwaltung
die später Raffinerie retten soll sehen
viele hier skeptisch
wir hatten es in den 90er Jahren schon
mal und deswegen diese ganze
treuhandsache ist auch eine Sache früher
Wohnen für 1 Euro Betriebe hier verkauft
wo wir auch mit Arbeitslosigkeit zu
kämpfen hatten also macht eine auch
Angst für die Zukunft auch das
petrolchemische Kombinat wird damals
privatisiert aber überlebt das Kürzel
PCK steht nun für petrolchemie und
Kraftstoffe findet sich im neuen
Namenszug wieder von den 1-8000
Mitarbeitern bleiben nur
1.200 übrig die Stadt verliert tausende
Einwohner ganze Wohnblocks stehen leer
und werden abgerissen
die die nicht in der Raffinerie weiter
arbeiten können verlassen die Stadt oder
bleiben ohne Arbeit zurück schon fünf
Jahre nach der Wende gründet sich hier
die Schwedter Tafel für Menschen in Not
eine der ersten in ganz Deutschland
aus allen Kulturschichten kommen die
Leute hierher das sind Rentner das sind
sogenannte Aufstocker also wo das Hartz
IV Geld oder die Arbeit nicht reicht
sondern das Hartz-IV-Geld dazu genommen
werden muss
Carmen Friedl ist seit Jahren arbeitslos
nun bekam sie über das Jobcenter hier
einen Minijob sie packt mit an ist froh
nun endlich wieder eine Aufgabe zu haben
also ich bin zufrieden dass man so einen
kleinen Minijob machen kann
als wenn man nur zu Hause rumsitzt weil
da weiß man auch nicht was man machen
soll
schon traurig alles also ich finde sehr
traurig mit dem PCR muss ich ehrlich
sagen es geht um viel die die in Schwedt
noch in der Industrie arbeiten können
werden gut bezahlt die Raffinerie bringt
bis heute Wohlstand für ihre
Beschäftigten für die ganze Stadt auch
hier wo man es gar nicht vermuten würde
ist die Raffinerie präsent diese Kita
hat besonders flexible Öffnungszeiten
Kinder können auch am Wochenende oder
nachts betreut werden wenn ihre Eltern
arbeiten müssen
das PCK ist einer unserer größten
Sponsoren
jährlich beteiligen die sich mit einer
bestimmten Summe daran einfach nur nicht
weil wir 1000 Kinderhaus im PCK hier
haben sondern weil die mit der Meinung
sind das muss es hier in Schwedt geben
auch andere wichtige Arbeitgeber
entsteht wie Theater Papierfabrik oder
Klinikum profitieren davon aber der
russische Staatskonzern rosnew ist
mehrheitseigener bei der PCK seit
Ausbruch des russischen Angriffskrieges
ein Problem der Bund als Treuhänder will
den Fortbestand der Raffinerie sichern
macht nun den Weg frei für einen
Kurswechsel
es ist für Schwedt und auch gerade für
die Raffinerie wichtig gewesen dass die
Partner die Vertragspartner nicht
abspringen dass das Unternehmen
sozusagen
entsanktioniert wurde mit dieser
Entscheidung um wichtige Dienstleister
weiter an Bord zu halten sechs Monate
hält der Bund nun seine Hand über die
Raffinerie um Arbeitsplätze zu
garantieren und eine Energieversorgung
ohne russisches Öl eigentlich glauben
wir dass wir egal was passiert eine gute
Chance haben dass es eine ausreichende
Versorgung mit Öl gibt so dass die
Raffinerie arbeiten kann und damit man
sich aber ganz sicher ist wenn man
Arbeiter oder Arbeiterinnen ist in der
Raffinerie Schwedt haben wir die
beschäftigungssicherungsmaßnahmen die
gehaltssicherungsmaßnahme der zugefügt
unsere Hoffnung ist die werden wenig
oder nur ab und zu gebraucht aber
eigentlich läuft es
die Versprechen die der Staat nun gibt
kommen beim Leiter der später Tafel gut
an
Moment habe ich den Eindruck versuchen
sie ihr Bestes dass hier zu unterstützen
einen Weg zu finden dass die
Arbeitsplätze bleiben mit dem Ausbau der
Pipeline und mit polnische auf
polnischer Seite was zu machen das hat
den Eindruck im Moment dass sie da
wirklich auf einen guten Weg sind diesen
Optimismus Teilen Zulieferbetriebe in
der Region nicht 100 Mitarbeiter sind in
diesem Bauunternehmen beschäftigt das
grenzüberschreitend agiert und einen
deutschen und polnischen Geschäftsführer
hat nicht nur deutsche Arbeitsplätze
hängen am Pck
das sind auch sehr viele polnische
Mitarbeiter die auch für sag mal so für
PCK und für die für die Firmen auch
arbeiten die Treuhandverwaltung so sehen
ist die Unternehmer hier ist ein
Zeitgewinn mehr nicht und irgendwo sind
ja die Grenzen des Staates auch hier
setzt also
kurzfristig ist es sicherlich erstmal
eine Chance aber wie gesagt also ich
glaube nicht dass es gut ist wenn der
Staat eben langfristig in der Wirtschaft
eingreift aus Sorge um ihrer Stadt und
die ganze Region haben sich diese Bürger
zusammengeschlossen das Bündnis Zukunft
Schwedt kämpft seit Monaten um
Öffentlichkeit fand schließlich Gehör
bei Land und Bund Robert Habeck war im
Mai vor Ort und stellte sich den Fragen
der PCK Mitarbeiter darum ging es immer
dafür zu sorgen dass hier nicht die
Lichter ausgehen sondern ganz im
Gegenteil Schwedt auf anderen Wegen
versorgt wird doch wo das Öl ab Januar
herkommen soll ist bis heute unklar
sorgt weiter für Fragen beim
Bürgerbündnis jetzt endlich sagen wir es
mal so ist Politik in die Puschen
gekommen hat eine Entscheidung getroffen
aber die ist tatsächlich bloß erst ein
erster Schritt ja der ist noch nichts
was jetzt wirklich gelöst ist wir haben
bis jetzt noch keine sicheren zusagen
dass über die dospar Pipeline aus Polen
wirklich Öl kommen das ist der Plan
das auch Anlagen runtergefahren werden
das auch Mitarbeiter in Kurzarbeit gehen
das ist eben dieser traurige dann
sicherlich sind sie jetzt mal
abgesichert aber trotzdem gehen sie
erstmal ein Kurzarbeit sie werden vom
Staat alimentiert ihre Sorgen Kreisen
nicht nur ums jetzt denn sie wissen
irgendwann werden Erdöl Raffinerien
Geschichte sein
dann hat na klar Transformationsprozess
da sind wir sehr dafür das wollen wir
gerne das ist glaube ich auch wichtig
wirklich auf lange Zeit gesehen weil ja
Raffinerie natürlich nicht mehr ewig
geht ja Bedarf wird irgendwann sinken
also wenn man nur auf auf Ölverarbeitung
bleibt ist man ja nicht langfristig
nicht Zukunft aber wir haben auch gesagt
wir wollen jetzt wissen was ist im
Januar fest steht auch ohne russisches
Öl soll es für die Menschen in Schwedt
eine gute Zukunft geben doch die sorgen
dass viele hier ihre Arbeit verlieren
wie eins nach der Wende sind groß